their eyes are always looking around
this a nice lunge and filled by
poisonous Anthony trying to set the
screen
[Applause]
good swing of the ball Galloway sure
[Applause]
blue chips he thought he was fouled by
Thompson
here is Anthony from Freeport said this
with the slam that was nasty
[Music]
people go slapped by porzingis
[Applause]
[Applause]
nice pass in his sophomore Cygnus to his
teammate shaved it on his head or Cygnus
steps back puts it on the floor drives
kristaps porzingis gets the crowd on its
feet
set of screens now erupted in the last
three minutes of the second quarter for
sickness as the shot clock expires
[Applause]
seconds remaining Williams back out the
porzingis from three and it's good at
the buzzer
chris stops porzingis Turner over they
run down for Lopez drives fakes stops
hook shot misses
execution here on the inbound eraklyon
goes to the basket the contour singers
porzingis has to throw out the three
[Applause]
singles grabs another rebound his third
there's that tournament Chuck misses
[Applause]
the service against Craig speak the gap
it's got seven points dazzling pass from
KPO he's hit his first point and three
missed his first six two red holes to
the ball laughs the things were
[Music]
[Applause]
for to read p2p ii see he crushes
the ball almost eludes him
[Applause]
seconds
florges some energy good defense on
Butler porzingis throws it down on a
beautiful pass from Lopez and the Bulls
call timeout him you know how to draw
that foul what a pass from porzingis and
Galloway holiday inside block by four
singers
oh what a rejection from up in the
scenario to see and again we talk so
much about free agents for seunga's to
Lopez
nice pass from porzingis and Lopez to
finish innings and rose four seconds to
go porzingis underneath flushes at home
and draws the foul porzingis paper
drives pull-up shot backs it in
my son finally slips it to Gasol short
rebound O'Quinn McHale dangerous outlet
pass the porzingis has it
that way time and time again yeah well
you can pick up the pace if you get
people to miss their shots nice pass and
a foul
kristaps porzingis again no field goals
in the last games first route Rose kicks
it out Lee off the dribble
stop lock by way better Costa for cygnus
for the easy two gets back to James
finds for sickness sent another reverse
slug it lets the second one of the game
Madison 69 guarding TV Oh force Angus
power grows it down on the reverse
Stanley Johnson
[Applause]
and the foul kristaps porzingis gets
them on their feet on a gorgeous feed
from Brandon Jennings defense can be a
best off this O'Quinn Drive spins back
almost lost it shot clock winding down
dribbles again pull-up jumper let's go
[Applause]
[Music]
porzingis power than its core Pilate
rush that one a bit right
[Applause]
kozminski stops back out holiday shot
clock winding down holidays got to get
it off just doesn't time can't hit
porzingis on the follow
Carmelo Anthony back in looks slip pass
porzingis drives underneath two throws
it down
[Applause]
it's out this time by KP and we did
which you don't get when he's out on the
three-point line so often again it's
finding the balance watson porzingis
[Music]
porzingis gets it the spin loop and
draws the foul and one I'll put it in on
a circus shot and a chance for a
three-point flood at 14 inch and the
officials Derek Colin Scott foster and
Aaron Smith's the alley for 4 seconds
look for a high-scoring game tonight the
last time the Knicks saw him he had 32
points and they've got to get up on him
horse hair strong moves to the home and
we featured up at the top of the Saudi
Amazing Grace by the 7/3
maker matched up with blood cell here's
holiday
Sweden is rose flicks it out to
porzingis great ball fake he drive
[Applause]
for Judas against coming in mix like the
height advantage there and there's your
reason why is porzingis gets his second
field goal
in fact their starting point guard
because of injuries to Frazier put up
grip numbers he can't even play now is
out of the rotation porzingis right
there
seven to shoot Thierry then a cool boat
trying to hold her in the airport Cygnus
the denial first he altered it then he
blocked it no down great second effort
by both players oh no for Z it's a
one-point game
this is his first opportunity tonight
and now porzingis gets a three to
creativity by leads at find him
patient's lead by five they've scored
eight consecutive points as dog is
protected by porzingis yeah giving it
back with the left hand
[Applause]
with Jennings in his skis Lee with
another three nine Portuguese he comes
out of the rafters pinch tabs on home is
that consecutive games a 39 points
except to control him
process was back to the basket than a
good play by KP that time porzingis
[Applause]
very erratic and sporadic play this
uphill intercepted but Jenny's comes up
and he deals it 2/4 his dunk and he's
fouled
[Applause]
Holliday porzingis fakes drives gets
across the lane
that made a run two caps blown attack
open again Jennings has been the hot
hand inside a for seunga's dribbles foul
shot good and one maybe you kind of sent
another night where there wasn't a lot
of defense early first team that comes
up with a big stop - away by - trying to
acclimate Durant early didn't warn his
and his good rhythm porzingis drives and
finishes boos from the crowd as
porzingis brings unexpected into in a
worse than the lead was 17 a game the
league averages 14 back door play
porzingis struck thomas said the Knicks
have cut the Nets lead to 11 it was
20-watt earlier this corner City that
time with the stuff the 6-foot zoo
chasing Randle now poor second off of
the block then he hold on to the basket
[Applause]
jingis throws it out of bounds with his
third rejection of the game since this
isn't what they needed from kpt night
without Melo Leonard drives block by
porzingis there he's averaging two again
Cooney's kozminski stripped up from
behind in those possessions knicks
played such a good defensive sequence
porzingis inside banks at home and a
foul
does not get the role in cousins has
another rebound
a tiptoe rebound by the way never moved
mops it up to porzingis any got oh my
goodness now that's terrific that guy
ladies and gentlemen this is one of the
coming stars in the NBA
we're sickest crossover down a lane goes
inside throws it down at a foul
and they will give him the continuation
everything was okay no man it was a
great feeling I really appreciate it
fell in love
forcing us inside throws it down again
see if we can find out while jeans came
out quickly or Zynga's tied up shoots
Ava Thompson and 2x as the shot clock
expires
[Applause]
and that gets the crowd
[Applause]
here comes Lane set the tone for the
Knicks the steal by Jackson rejected
five seconds
turnover by the way Elliot took
incentives and he throws it down
leave foul line jumper soft-touch one
tip down tended by young the head to
stevenson steven seagal still pacer ball
porzingis got a piece of in his second
block of the game a similar scenario
[Applause]
five seniors - laughs terrific hook by
the rookie in it's a 10-point game it
comes Hardaway Jared Jared throws it up
porzingis piece
Wow thirteen portraits already and the
Knicks have their first lead and I have
to put it up jock like a tooth Bolsover
move just gets it off in time and knocks
it down
the ability to put it on the floor or
sink is back to nil Akina
fakes the three looks
gorgeous be minced Indiana against
Charlotte sub mark first half how to
make a quick comeback porzingis gets
away porzingis sometimes to Jack Jack
drives Jack digs it out porzingis half
the release does rattles at home 3/4 for
porzingis as the shot clock expired nose
run in the paint for holidays it's
trying to push porzingis riding the
floor in the finish and a quick timeout
from it Fred Hoiberg there's Jack coming
off a season high 19 points on Sunday
night walls 3
kristaps porzingis
with eight points in about a minute as
close to this year frustrated is not
starting frustrated at times not playing
but he's statement women porzingis with
the finish
ten points were porzingis dingus kicks
it out to Jarrett Jack back back out for
zingers two to three from downtown and
now has 26 Jack can get penetration off
the zoobel jack the porzingis throws it
down tie game and a timeout call by New
Orleans the low reset or Zynga Stearns
again sports up with spin moves nice -
the man shot beauty there from kristaps
porzingis he's got 18 each of those
teams you saw then that stretches had
very good sequences
[Applause]
nice spindles in the paint that many
points and it's not just going inside
fires away guarded by AC or Zynga's
fires a three that's good
four for four from downtown for Zynga's
and Linux Bank up by 16
[Applause]
it's over last year is at 77 most of his
numbers what's up you guys this Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for some more video
content